Speaker 1: Let's start today with Joe Biden's
first State of the Union address, many of
you wrote to me, you said, David, I remember
in 2021, Joe Biden gave a State of the Union
address. Yes, he basically did, except in
a president's first year in office. That first
joint address to the House and Senate is not
called a State of the Union address, so this
was the first State of the Union address by
name. But the second one in spirit, I guess
we would say overall it was OK. It was OK.
I mean, I'll give you kind of my more wrap
up overall review after we look at some clips.
But I think Joe Biden's sort of struck the
right note and tone overall and in particular
with Ukraine, Russia, that was probably the
strongest part. And he opened with that. There
was a bunch in the middle that was very so-so
and a lot of kind of vague throwing out things
he's going to do, which will obviously never
see the light of day with absolutely no explanation
as to how some of those things would even
be possible. And we will get to that. But
overall, this is you have to remember, this
is a particularly weaponized Republican Party
whose goal is just stop Biden at any opportunity
stop. Just don't let him do anything. And
given that context, it is difficult to put
together a speech that Republicans in any
and any real wear are going to be satisfied
by. But let's just get right into it. Joe
Biden opening up with a statement of solidarity
with Ukraine
Speaker 2: six days ago, Russia's Vladimir
Putin sought to shake the very foundations
of the free world, thinking he could make
it bend to his menacing ways. But he badly
miscalculated. He thought he could roll into
Ukraine and the world would roll over. Instead,
he met with a moral wall of strength he never
anticipated or imagined. He met the Ukrainian
people.
Speaker 1: So the tone here was the right
tone, and again, he he started strong and
this was really one of the better parts of
the speech, continuing on to talk about new
restrictions, sanctions, limitations on Russia
and Russian oligarchs, and again also played
very well with the crowd.
Speaker 2: Tonight, I say to the Russian oligarchs
and the corrupt leaders who built billions
of dollars off this violent regime. No more
the United States.
Unidentified: I mean it.
Speaker 2: The United States Department of
Justice is assembling a dedicated task force
to go after the crimes of the Russian oligarchs.
We're joining with European allies to find
and seize their yachts, their luxury apartments,
their private jets. We're coming for you.
Ill gotten gains, and tonight I'm announcing
that we will join our allies in closing off
American airspace to all Russian flights.
Further isolating
Unidentified: Russia. And that an additional
squeeze on her.
Speaker 1: So more restrictions and those
well received and the restrictions make sense,
the only caveat is we do want to make sure
that all Americans that are in Russia can
get home. Obviously, the signals to those
in Ukraine for a while have been get out.
But we want to make sure that Americans in
Russia can get home, but all popular, sensible
things to be doing. And again, Republicans
basically clapping for just about everything
Joe Biden said on the issue of Russia, Ukraine
Speaker 2: and states and our allies will
defend every inch of territory that is NATO's
territory for the full force of our collective
power. Every single inch.
Speaker 1: OK, so that stuff very strong and
very popular with the entire crowd, and then
it became a more typical state of the Union
address Republicans, for example, booing when
Joe Biden correctly points out Donald Trump's
tax cuts disproportionately benefited the
rich. They did. And Republicans boo either
because they don't believe it or because they
don't like that. It's being pointed out.
Speaker 2: Unlike the $2 trillion tax cut
passed in the previous administration that
benefited the top one percent of Americans
the American Rescue Plan. The American Rescue
Plan help working people and left no one behind.
Speaker 1: So a bit of a strange, false start
there from Chuck Schumer, but the Republicans
booing Joe Biden's comment about who benefited
from Donald Trump's tax cuts, although what
Joe Biden said was perfectly accurate at then
at at an almost immediately subsequent point.
Joe Biden talks about what has been record
job growth under the Biden administration,
and of course, it is true. And we can flesh
that out further by talking about this sort
of unique COVID recovery period in which Joe
Biden started his presidency. Needless to
say, at one point, the camera points to Mitch
McConnell and McConnell. McConnell looks like
he had some bad clams before the event upon
hearing about record job growth
Speaker 2: and created jobs lots of jobs.
In fact, our economy created over six point
five million new jobs just last year.
Unidentified: More job? In one year than ever
before in the
Speaker 2: history of the United States of
America. The economy grew at a rate of 5.7
last year, the strongest growth rate in 40
years and the first step in bringing fundamental
changes in our economy. It hasn't worked for
working people in this nation for too long
for the past 40 years, and
Speaker 1: there is Mitch McConnell who just
looks like something was wrong with the muscles,
if you know what I mean at dinner beforehand.
Then Joe Biden started getting into some of
sort of the general policy ideas, and a lot
of them made for OK rhetoric. But I'm going
to be honest with you guys. A lot of these
are basically impossibilities. Let's listen
to the first one.
Speaker 2: That means make more cars and semiconductors
in America, more infrastructure and innovation
in America, more goods moving faster and cheaper
in America, more jobs where we can earn a
good living in America instead of relying
on foreign supply chains. Let's make it in
America. Economist. Economist. That means
so,
Speaker 1: you know, I think this is one of
those things where it this is the epitome
of the absurdity of American politics. Republicans
who say they're all about building by American
are mostly just sitting after Joe Biden says
We're going to build and buy American. So
first of all, I thought Republicans wanted
that, and then all of a sudden they're sitting
down and it's just political trash. At the
same time, we have an economy based on not
building American. And what I mean by that
is decades ago, the decision was made implicitly.
It's not that someone one day said, let's
structure our entire economy on cheap stuff
from China and other countries. Nobody said
that. But through cumulative decisions about
labor and about outsourcing and about trade,
the collective implicit decision was made.
We would rather pay less for stuff, but get
it from places like China and to do the build
and buy American thing that Joe Biden is talking
about. It would raise prices on those things
in the United States. It just it would, and
it would take at minimum, eight to 10 years
to start making a lot of those changes. So
I'm not saying it's good or bad. I'm pointing
out the absurdity of a president saying it's
going to be great when we do this thing, which
all of us over the last 40 years have decided
not to do. We've actually done the opposite
through our trade and other regulations and
agreements. But also, it's something Republicans
claim to want. But they don't care when Joe
Biden says it's like the those 25 seconds
are the epitome of everything that's sort
of broken with American politics now the most
vile moment of the entire speech, and we will
focus in on this. More later was when Joe
Biden was talking. About his son, Beau, who
died of cancer. And Lauren Boebert yells out
disgustingly, you've been there.
Speaker 2: I've been in and out of Iraq and
Afghanistan over 40 times these burn pits
and incinerate waste, the waste of war, medical
and hazardous material, jet fuel and so much
more. And they come home many of the world's
fittest and best trained warriors in the world,
never the same headaches, numbness, dizziness,
a cancer that will put them in a flag draped
coffin. I know firsthand. One of those. So
one of those soldiers is my son, Major.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that was that was Lauren
Boebert, and we're going to talk about that
a little later, one of the most, the most
disgusting moment I ever remember from any
state of the Union. Joe Biden then talking
about corporations and the wealthy paying
higher taxes. And Elizabeth Warren liked it.
Speaker 2: Not going to punish anybody. But
let's make corporations and wealthy Americans
start paying their fair share.
Unidentified: Good. Last year. Last year,
Speaker 1: so Elizabeth Warren liking that
one understandingly, understandably then a
sort of kind of like a muted we've done pretty
well and are ready to kind of start moving
on from COVID. Not like the huge mission accomplished,
but sort of one.
Speaker 2: For more than two years, COVID
has impacted every decision in our lives and
the life of this nation. And I know you're
tired, frustrated and exhausted and don't
even count as close to a million people who
sit at a dining room table or kitchen table
look at an empty chair because they lost somebody.
But I also know this because of the progress
we've made, because of your resilience and
the tools that we have been provided by this
Congress tonight, I can say we're moving forward
safely back to a normal, normal, more normal
routines. We've reached a new moment in the
fight against COVID 19, so
Speaker 1: a sort of soft victory declaration,
which I think is OK, it's what was expected,
and it's basically warranted by the numbers
that we are seeing. At another point, Joe
Biden talking about the importance of funding
police funding police all agree.
Speaker 2: The answer is not to defund the
police is to fund the police.
Speaker 1: One man. So some on the left are
taking that as a direct attack on the progressive
movement, but the truth is the majority of
the progressive movement doesn't actually
want to defund the police. We want to fix
the police and that's that's the reality.
Lastly, Joe Biden again finishing strong on
the topic of Ukraine and go get him, go get
him the final line of the night.
Speaker 2: And I've come to report on the
state of the nation, the State of the Union.
And my report is this the state of the Union
is strong because you, the American people,
are strong. We are stronger today.
Unidentified: We are stronger today than we
were a year ago. And will be stronger a year
from
Speaker 2: now than we are today. This is
our moment to meet and overcome the challenges
of our time.
Unidentified: And we will as one people, one
America, the United
Speaker 2: States of America.
Unidentified: God bless you. May God protect
our troops. Thank you.
Speaker 2: Go get in.
Speaker 1: Go get him. Seemingly, apparently
related to Vladimir Putin, so OK, my my honest
rating, if I just say this is what it was.
With normal standards, right? I mean, Trump
really threw off our barometer, but with normal
standards, this was probably a b. The opening
Ukraine section was good. It was the right
tone. The entire speech was probably the right
tone and energy. There were endless, disjointed
transitions that were extraordinarily abrupt.
A lot of very vague ideas thrown out at one
point, Joe Biden saying, We're going to crack
down on people charging customers too much
for for things like, are you suggesting price
controls like that? That's a really big deal.
What are you talking about? Are you proposing
legislation? Absolutely no idea. And I understand
it's a state of the Union. You don't lay out
everything in detail, but there were so many
of those things thrown out, which are obviously
never going to see the light of day. So I
would give it a b overall with many elements
that were what was needed given the situation
in Ukraine and Russia not made easier overall
by the fact that the Republican Party has
become a parody of itself. So that's my thought.
Let's now talk about the most vile moment
ever in a State of the Union address